the question of sort of a manger
discovery point as a single event is
often asked most noble prizes are given
I believe for technical advances or
because such moments are identifiable in
the discovery of techniques monoclonal
antibodies patch clamping and so on much
fewer nobel prize is actually giving for
discoveries of how something works which
is because in my personal view most
discoveries of how something works are
not discoveries that can be in capacitor
encapsulated in a single moment their
discoveries that require an incremental
advance over many different experiments
if you want to understand the process
you can understand it in a single
experiment you have to approach it for
many different angles in my personal
case the work that we performed that I
think led to this prize was actually
work that initiated 25 years ago and
there were a lot of important
observations but in the end the promise
of these observations only materialized
style became more concrete very recently
because continuing experiments in our
lab back them up expanded them explain
them and gave them substance and so I
actually don't think that there was any
single Eureka moment in my career there
were many small Eureka moments but not
just one discovery it's in fact the
whole question I'm working on
and I think that our work has
contributed understanding a process that
involves all the necessities more than
understanding one little thing or one
big thing but understanding really how
it works